how are you doing today i'm successful
how are you doing today
i'm doing very good i appreciate you
including me on your speed dating today
thanks
but i'm not i'm not dating but
i'm getting to know everyone
got it uh i just want to start by saying
uh how much i enjoyed this movie and
your performance so how much how much
did you enjoy i i thought paul did a
fantastic job with this film right he
did it
oh no he really did um i am curious
though what was it about this script
that said um i have to do this
um well
it was more so paul at first and then
when i read the script it totally
resonated with me because i know so many
people like willa tell that like they're
really talented in this one thing but
they're hiding it's like they're
covering especially in the comedy world
i meet so many guys that are like you
know
super talented on stage but then on
stage they're very like closed off and
standoffish and it's like what's going
on tell me what's up and then eventually
they open up and tell you everything and
you're like well i get why you were so
close off okay
one of the things about this film though
is that oscar does so much by doing so
little and i'm curious what is it like
playing across from him when he's doing
this and did you take anything away from
watching him work that you're like oh i
need to use that in like a future movie
oh yes well first of all i was learning
so much from him and like i didn't real
like as a comedian you know as a
comedian you have to do things you got
to be physical you know use your face
use all your instruments all the time
right and then working with him
and i'm seeing him be completely still
no movement
nothing
but i understand everything he's saying
without saying anything does that make
sense and i'm just like how does he do
that and that so i would practice
and i'll be having thoughts
and i feel like a dumbass but i'm
learning i'm learning
it's but it's easier it's so much easier
to do that
than to do what i do and i'm like i
gotta get more of that in my life
more of what oscar's doing because it's
easier
um it just feels uncomfortable because
i'm so used to being
you know big and shiny and
sparkly but you can still be shiny and
sparkly
without doing anything
yeah
i would imagine i completely agree i
would imagine that when you were
researching you must have learned a lot
about gamblers and things you didn't
know what's like the one or two things
you're like
really surprised you
well
the whole okay so
not much because i got a lot of friends
that are professional gamblers i guess
the amount of hours that they spend
playing poker surprise me
um and how they'll pause the game and
come back the next day like
uh that shocked me uh i'm like what like
just finish the damn that like
finished uh but they'll
uh they can last a while
uh
but yeah there's did you know some
people wear diapers when they play
i did not know that but now that you say
it it wouldn't surprise me
it shocked the hell out of me
that's like
an
ass person go to the bathroom
right i don't think i could sit in my
own feces while playing poker but that's
just me
but that that's me too i couldn't do it
but i mean
if it's whatever whatever it flows your
boat i guess it's your thing they don't
want to get up from the table they don't
want to get up from the table
imagine it's like something smells like
[ __ ] what is that [ __ ]
before i run out of time and i'm about
to be out of time i am so excited for
the nick cage movie the un
the unbearable weight of massive talent
which is coming out next year it is like
my most anticipated film i know you're a
part of it um what can you tease people
um i can tell you this
the movie is funny but i'm not
i am not funny at all
okay i'm the straight straightest
straight man which i'm glad i got to
work with is oscar before i did that one
because
yeah
very straight
i will leave it there and just say i
cannot wait to see it for real
me too
hey listen congrats on being part of
this uh and thank you for giving me your
time today thank you i appreciate you
stephen i look forward to seeing you
again thank you great conversation i
have fun with you